everyone I'm all turbine easy I can this
is top five I don't know about you but I
love Power Rangers with the new movie
coming out this weekend I thought I'd
get the worst out of the way first so we
can spend next week talking all about
the best episodes of the original show
this week though I'm bringing you the
top 5 Mighty Morphin Power Ranger
episodes that aren't so more phenomenal
I'm pretty big into this series through
in space so if you want more Power
Rangers talk subscribe to my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome Walter
I have an unboxing video up over there
that you guys will probably enjoy this
long lasting pop-culture phenomenon
debuted in 1993 and basically took over
the world money Morphin Power Rangers
lasted for three long seasons produced a
theatrically released movie and laid the
groundwork for a show that has kept
going for the most part for the last 24
years using footage from the Japanese
series Super Sentai Power Rangers mixed
in American teenagers from the out of
costume portion of the show and created
a hit while a lot of people look back on
this show fondly myself included there
are some really bad episodes of this
show that detractors can easily point
out I'd advise not bringing these up
when trying to convince someone the show
is worth 3 watching these of a top 5
worst episodes of Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers number 5 story book rangers
parts 1 and 2 from season 2 after about
the midway point of the second season
Power Rangers finally began taking
chances and started changing up the
status quo some of the resulting
episodes were really good and some of
them were like this Rita trapped
Kimberley Tommy and rocky in a book
called grumble the magic elf the only
way out is to finish the story inside
but that proved difficult when a swarm
of putties arrived to disrupt the events
of the book which leave the three
Rangers stuck until they can find an
alternate way out meanwhile Aisha Billy
and Adam do their best to aid the others
from the outside world this is probably
the most unnecessary two-parter of the
whole show it features some terrible
nineties TV show green screen and is
definitely one of the sillier situation
the Rangers have ever been in the
effects can be distractingly bad here
there's a scene where they don't even
see out the Green River goes up to my
dog or I turn you and your friends into
seaweed in part 2
rhydian's ed bring Vulcan sculls failed
attempt at making a monster to life in
Turkey jerk also Rita says the magician
from the book is an old friend of hers
what she's friends with a character from
a children's book that magician mondo is
another example of these episodes
bottom-of-the-barrel effects
[Music]
it's one of the worst episodes from an
uneven season but like I mentioned
before at least they were trying new
things to mix it up this is one story
book you don't want to read now you're
not the model of the story doesn't get
out of my book
number four trick or treat from season
one the worst monster of the entire
series is in this episode skull and
Kimberley compete on a Halloween themed
game show but when Rita's new Monster
the pumpkin wrapper is let loose
Kim has to bail on her TV debut and join
the other Rangers and flooding this hip
hop heavy it's as dreadful as it sounds
welcome to buff up get back but if you'd
like to play okay we thought what's
on your bus Beulah Becca
unfortunately the pumpkin wrapper isn't
the only thing that tries to rap in this
episode come on guys let's wait to touch
the blood yeah take our treat you're
incomplete so the Power Rangers you
can't be oh you are punking me the host
of the game show is an actor who shows
up again playing a couple other
characters here he's just unsettling in
the wrong way
though
[Music]
this episode is just bad it'll make you
mad and not even attack it's the
opposite of rad and won't make you glad
good thing it was just a fad now this is
just sad
number 3 Wild West Rangers parts 1 & 2
from season 2 these episodes aired right
after the storybook Rangers two-parter
so it wasn't a good couple weeks there
Kimberly is stranded in the Wild West
and discovers the great-great-great
grandparents of all the other current
Rangers who all look and act almost
exactly like their 1990s counterparts
that sends Goldar the cactus monster
needle nose and a pack of putty to 1880
to destroy the isolated pink ranger
however the quick-thinking kim has an
idea that may just save the day I'm sure
this was fun to shoot maybe it sounded
like a good idea on paper but it
resulted in two of the worst episodes of
the series
this is Power Rangers I can buy a lot of
the random explanations they give for
things in the show but even by those
standards this was pretty dumb miss
Kimmy you wouldn't be trying to
Hornswoggle me now would eventually
Kimberly has the idea to teleport to the
1880 version of the command center and
explain to Zordon and alpha what's going
on she convinced them to give her the
other four original Power coins and
distributes them amongst the ancestors
of the current Rangers with the help of
Tommy's own ancestor the white stranger
Rocko Abraham myth Alicia and William
morph into the Wild West Rangers one
time
[Music]
okay new Power Ranger
look at these manly does yep
that happened on top of all this is a
really annoying monster voice for needle
nose can see a varmint vomit
i'ma flash don't you guys know anything
like that CG situation in at least this
is a nice focus on Kimberly she became
one of the show's best characters as it
went on and by her departure in the
third season she may have actually been
the most developed it's close to certain
time in any case these aren't episodes
I'd go back to check out when we
watching the show
[Music]
[Applause]
number two for Whom the Bell trolls from
season 1 this was an early episode of
the show when I was still trying to find
its footing I can give a lot of episodes
from that period of pass but not this
one Reeta cast a spell on trainees all
mister ticklesneezer and turns them into
a hesitant adversary for the Power
Rangers ticklesneezer doesn't want to
destroy but only collect and this upsets
the angry Empress however all things may
not be as we see from top to bottom this
episode failed in all departments from a
character perspective and makes Trini
and Billy look like little wimps the
editing of the Super Sentai footage into
this episode is also not exactly
seamless what the hell was that why is a
little kid standing next to the Megazord
and why did they leave that in finally
from a writing and story standpoint this
episode just doesn't add up
it's revealed at the end that
ticklesneezer being turned into one of
Rita's monsters and the fight with the
Power Rangers was all a dream of
training why that doesn't make any sense
at all usually you'd have a nightmare
scenario where everything goes bad and
it's revealed that it was all a dream
most of the time that's a cop-out ending
to a story but at least it follows a
recognizable structure and this episode
trees dream plays out fine it's like a
normal episode of the show everything
turns out okay at the end so why did
they tack on the dream gimmick this was
decently close to being the worst
but there is one that tough duo would
you bother like oh and what I failed eh
you'll do it that day and the number one
works Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
episode is I'm dreaming of a white
ranger from season 3
take it away Zoran rito revolto has
taken over the North Pole he's captured
Santa and is forcing the elves to
mass-produce Lord says evil Christmas
toy because of a combination of the
North Pole unique polarity and a cross
current of holiday magic your morphing
powers will not work there everything
about this episode is so ridiculous it
doesn't even use any Super Sentai
footage this doesn't feel like a Power
Rangers episode since the Rangers can't
use their powers at the North Pole
they fight reader 1
Goldar by throwing snowballs at them by
the way this Santa doesn't even ho ho he
ha ha what kind of Santa ha ha are you
kidding me this is the time of miracles
and the dad of this little girl has the
same reaction whenever we see him
apparently this episode was released on
VHS a few months before it aired on TV
but it did err and because it did it is
the worst episode of muddy Morphin Power
Rangers now that we get that out of the
way next week we can focus on the top 5
best episodes of the show I'm looking
forward to it and so should you
in the meantime enjoy the new movie this
weekend I want to hear what you guys
who the hell are you I'm here to deliver
the truth there are no good episode of
Power Rangers Rob that's right I'm not
gonna look you slowly live anymore
that show sucks then and that show sucks
now and you know it how dare you how
dare I hold their eyes
once you go throw in a few episodes of
Jam lizard-breath ha ha tough talk I'm a
guy who's all alone oh I'm not alone
[Music]
hello hey Walter Power Rangers huh yeah
hey hang on a second okay to Emperor's
New Groove Porter hello
no Walter I am NOT being a Power Ranger
we've been over this
the answer is no no out we want one one
Walter hey what's going on Oh Power
Rangers uh-huh oh you know what though I
don't I don't really like dressing up
anymore so um yeah I don't think I'm
going to be available for that mm-hmm
yeah sorry
uh-huh yeah next time later bye Jim okay
okay I guess I am all alone
[Music]
you
rita cast a spell on Trinis doll mister
ticklesneezer and turns into effect
sniffing oh how dare I how oh my
[Laughter]
ruins the moment that's at your post
credits sequence right there